HAVE CONTINUED OVER
AND GRABBED THE STICK
BECAUSE KURALY HAD TO
DO THE SAME,  BUT
BERGERON DID A NICE
JOB AVOIDING THE
PENALTY AND PLAYING
THE BODY ALONG THE
WALL DEFENSIVELY TO
CREATE A TURNOVER.
>> Jack: KURALY
UNABLE TO CONTROL THE
FACE-OFF.
LINDHOLM WITH ZACHA
AND  PASTRNAK,  AND
SCORES!
99 POINTS FOR NUMBER
88, AND THE BRUINS
HAVE THEIR RECORD-
SETTING FRANCHISE
VICTORY, AND THE ROAD
TO THE STANLEY CUP
GOES THROUGH TD
GARDEN!
THE BRUINS HAVE  WON
THEIR THIRD RESIDENCE
TROPHY IN 10 SEASONS.
THIS FRANCHISE HAS
BEEN AROUND FOR 99
YEARS. THEY NEVER
HAVE WON 58 GAMES IN
A SEASON.
UNTIL TONIGHT!
>> Andy: WELL, IF YOU
WANT A  BLUEPRINT OF
HOW TO INVOLVE DAVID
PASTRNAK IN OVERTIME,
THIS IS IT.
LOOK AT THE SCREEN.
HE IS BEHIND LINDHOLM
WITHOUT THE PUCK, AND
HE JUST EXPLODES
THROUGH CENTER ICE,
AND LINDHOLM DELIVERS
A PERFECT TAPE TO
TAPE PASS.
THREE ON THREE.
BOTH TEAMS MADE A
CHANGE.
STARTED THE SHIP,
TOOK THE DRAW, ZACHA
CAME OUT BUT YOU CAN
SEE COLUMBUS MAKING A
CHANGE AS WELL, BUT
PASTRNAK HAS THE
ADVANTAGE.
GENERATES SPEED
THROUGH CENTER ICE.
NO STOPPING HIM THERE.
THAT IS WHEELHOUSE.
ATTACKING THE NET
FULL FLIGHT ON YOUR
FOREHAND.
NICE MOVE TO THE
BACKHAND, MADE IT
LOOK EASY.
WHAT A PLAY BY
LINDHOLM AGAIN.